[Music]
you're overseeing the delivery of
crucial supplies to a rebel base deep in
the heart of enemy territory to get past
Imperial customs all packages must
follow a strict protocol if a box is
marked with an even number on the bottom
it must be sealed with a red top the
boxes are already being loaded onto the
transport when you receive an urgent
message one of the four boxes was sealed
incorrectly but they lost track of which
one all the boxes are still on the
conveyor belt two are facing down one
marked with a four and one with a seven
the other two are facing up one with a
black top another with a red one you
know that any violation of the protocol
will get the entire shipment confiscated
and put your allies in grave danger but
any boxes you pull off for inspection
won't make it on to this delivery run
depriving the rebels of critically
needed supplies the transport leaves in
a few moments with or without its cargo
which box or boxes should you grab off
the conveyor belt
it may seem like you need to inspect all
four boxes to see what's on the other
side of each but in fact only two of
them matter let's look at the protocol
again all it says is that even-numbered
boxes must have a red top it doesn't say
anything about odd-numbered boxes so we
can just ignore the box marked with a 7
what about the box with a red top don't
we need to check that the number on the
bottom is even as it turns out we don't
the protocol says that if a box has an
even number then it should have a red
top it doesn't say that only boxes with
even numbers can have red tops or that a
box with a red top must have an even
number the requirement only goes in one
direction so we don't need to check the
box with the red lid we do however need
to check the one with the black lid to
make sure it wasn't incorrectly placed
on an even numbered box if you initially
assumed the rules imply a symmetrical
match between the number on the box and
the type of lid you're not alone that
error is so common we even have a name
for it affirming the consequent or the
fallacy of the converse this fallacy
wrongly assumes that just because a
certain condition is necessary for a
given result it must also be sufficient
for it for instance having an atmosphere
is a necessary condition for being a
habitable planet but this doesn't mean
that it's a sufficient condition planets
like Venus have atmospheres but lack
other criteria for habitability if that
still seems hard to wrap your head
around let's look at a slightly
different problem imagine the boxes
contain groceries you see one marked for
shipment to a steak house and one to a
vegetarian restaurant then you see two
more boxes turned upside down one
labelled as containing meat and another
as containing onions which ones do you
need to check well it's easy make sure
the meat isn't being shipped to the
vegetarian restaurant and that the Box
going the air doesn't contain meat the
onions can go to either place and the
Box bound for the steak house
contain either product why does this
scenario seem easier formerly it's the
same problem two possible conditions for
the top of the box and two for the
bottom but in this case they're based on
familiar real-world needs and we easily
understand that while vegetarians only
eat vegetables they're not the only ones
who do so in the original problem the
rules seemed more arbitrary and when
they're abstracted that way the logical
connections become harder to see in your
case you've managed to get enough
supplies through to enable the
resistance to fight another day and you
did it by thinking outside the box both
sides of it and now for a completely
different riddle that also involves four
boxes each of these boxes contains a
different type of food the labels
identify the correct foods but exactly
three of the four have been applied to
the wrong box how many boxes do you have
to open to guarantee that you can always
identify the one that is correctly
labeled this bonus riddle comes courtesy
of our sponsor brilliant org it's just
one of thousands of riddles brilliant
features to help you build mastery
identify misconceptions and truly
understand concepts like logical
reasoning to develop your intuition
visit brilliant org slash ted-ed
in the first 833 of you to use that link
will get a 20% discount off the annual
subscription and finally you can find a
link to the solution to brilliance
mislabeled box riddle in the description
below